[Musique]
du
non
mais vous êtes là ça les diamants enfin
voyons bonvaux la réunion bonjour le
monde
comment il est oui c'est moi dans un
télé aujourd'hui encore une fois pour ne
pas sorti de l'auberge
aujourd'hui on arrive par le sentier de
la mare dans des eaux de la petite île
on monte vers le domaine du relais on va
voir monsieur eddy barré qui va nous
faire visiter son exploitation agricole
où entre autres il y a des carottes
on aura toutes les yeux bleus dès que
l'émission était miné vieux blues tout
le monde spéciale dédicace
alors moi ce que je vous invite à faire
c'est de me suivre tout simplement
ok arrive bien cela a bien raison ou
bien nato a besoin ou la paix anciens
beaumont
barrot nommé yapo nous pas besoin ou la
création beaumont
warhol au mieux mon doudou a besoin ou
la paix tient beaumont
nous on me suis dit comment il est j'ai
l'impression de vous connaître les
vacanciers j'ai l'impression que vous
connaître ce cas là c'est sûr alors
comment ils voient ça va beau temps est
revenu va donc surveiller les deux rives
est aussi super diamant un petit peu du
coup ça nous les et ben quoi au fait bon
ben là on est sur un coin de vestiaire
précisément au domaine du relais
donc je fais du maréchal divers sur
trois hectares paraît kuna des carottes
super jolie et une plantation de
carreaux de super rebelle
donc ma mise à l'eau du bain moi oui
mais apparemment ça marche parce qu'il
fonctionne pas on détaillera beaucoup de
crédit à long terme on y fait tout ça
tient beaumont ménehould et l'amour
[Musique]
allez allons monter donc là on ne m'a
donc des carreaux ouais ça a été chaud
naissains janvier et hommes
dis moi où nana une saison exprès
pommette de carreaux tenter la carotte à
la réunion va dire c'est toute l'année
c'est tout l'art des variétés que les
adapter en hiver il ya des variétés
d'été suivant les saisons vont changer
et cette variété la ccoim ça c'est la
serbe à heathrow lamastre m de toute
façon tous les variétés de carros et on
va dire cdc un concert il ya la soprano
la maille seront jugés pour les taraude
pause
chanter l'amour du tout cas mon coffre
et on la suit la courbe et y est on se
promène on va dire sur l'année c'est à
peu près à environ 1 et en lettonie 4 1
et à l'intérim et carottes et des mots
vides aux antilles pour les al ahmar
petit bonhomme c'est quoi cette musique
la cdu voir fil du bois field heureuse
pour parler de carotte c'est fatigués
bon faudra vite finir édition se situe
fatigué mon petit donc les guînois
musiciens c'est une autre plantation
coiffer mais celle là les plus petits
sanaa le stade d un mois pour un mois
après sur un mois de cela et si la
vétérante et depuis quand depuis fin
janvier
puisqu'en janvier et ça c'est la lune de
février on essaye de regarder la lune
pour les pour mettre les seniors surtout
surtout pour la cote à carros et c'est
quelque chose qui pendant son
directement sur bon après y'a des fois
on n'a pas le choix parce que quand la
pluie tombe souvent c'est la lune qui
fausse mais bien plus simple quand on
peut
paul marché local traitement parce que
moi j'ai dit ça on a créé une
association d'accord pour la philia
carottes dont je suis le président mais
monsieur tout ce qu'on veut montrer au
consommateur sait que la carotte pays
allant crowe est encore là et encore
présents sur la région c'est un moment
il y avait presque disparu
suite aux importations elles les agréent
des agriculteurs ont baissé les bras
parce que dit il ya de la peau et de la
carotte payer trouve plus preneur et
suite à ça on avait fait une petite
journée d'information sur mon terrain et
on avait remis la carotte en avant et de
cuissage trouve que la carro tard d'un
repas de la rue elle est repartie de
plus belle
je consomme le calme hommage excuse me
disait tu consommes local ans envoyons
des produits de mai et produits non
merci non mais ça va pas non 1
alors là ils voyagent sait pas où la
balle lors d'un un bon petit carottes
les biens tout les chouettes sacem
quitté la réunion pour différencier la
carotte pour l'accord votre pc
absolument moi j'ai plus de manger quand
400 fans d'al gore que des carottes et
kroon
quand du ballon d'ivoire gbagbo
la carotte dans sa cave au dixième
bougie de la carotte
autant donc la cave du domaine de la
carotte beaucoup détruit lundi la
carotte pays là nos côtés a dit qu'on
casse un nombre de sentiers sahraouis
qui les montrent un disque où la cen-sad
monde sur sa façon à bono carottes et
dis moi tu me disais que on a vu des
trucs à dire quand même c'est justement
cette carotte d'un pur par rapport aux
règles malheureusement qui échappent qui
échappe pas pour tout le monde demande
secoue aujourd'hui gsm de la carotte
jusqu'à la récolte on peut faire un
prélèvement nous résidions qu'est ce
qu'on a mis dans nos 40 pourrait si ce
n'est pas contaminé voir et
contrairement aux carottes d'impôts ils
ont passé non blancs on peut on ne peut
pas savoir ce qui ce qu'il ya devant
aller mais on dit ça on dit rien on va
retenir la bonne humeur pas messieurs
dames
la carotte
edit les carottes et autres d'ailleurs
coucou fait légumes coupés ou ça vous
remet ça
ça va sur des marchés les particuliers
vient comment ça se passe non moi je
fais aucun mort ni marché de grozny
marchait fort contrairement à van avant
je faisais les manches et moi je livre
tous les petits pains légumes tout le
matin et on fait quoi d'autre on en a
donc des carottes m'avait vu une hausse
du titre est aussi à wes a précédé
bloodshow l'artichaut aussi une fois par
foncer vers septembre octobre est
appréciée on va dire c est que le coeur
je mets en place tous les semaines c'est
la salle d'arts des débris divers et
brett divers mois divers droite de tim
roth chinois bright moutarde de braine
salle et brendan tu peux tout les bras
tendus que les gens il ya un billet mais
il peut consommer un bon petit bouillon
de brède des signes bourillon ou
[Musique]
mais même à londres lundi sera piraté
les légumes par aloysie devant moi c'est
du lard on est des humains c'est des
salaires c'est quoi pour le bénéfice de
faire autant de cultures nos fraises
brède carottes salades ce que c'est un
plaisir c'est aussi un lens et surtout
soucieux de planter plusieurs choses
mais deux pas de la même famille
d'accord parce que c'est ça sa peine et
de faire la rotation des cultures
d'ailleurs si on met de la même famille
un jour ou l'autre on va se retrouver
avec des problèmes sanitaires de maladie
que l'a rappelé en tête samedi du dard
habitué des maladies comme le gingembre
et deux en deux ans il ya aura pas de
culture après on revient avec ne revient
que notre culture mais pas la même
famille trois quarts où là on n'aura
plus besoin
soit ça va devoir et au lieu d'avoir des
salades radis la rotation
lors du duel herbaut sait toujours où la
patinoire gp il faut me écrit premier
lady ou ce moment là dans cette
exploitation mais ça va un petit peu
plus maintenant comment on va arriver à
face mais c'est que wayne d'ailleurs
voilà raconte comment un petit peu
tout ça c'est déjà le fils d'agriculteur
il nous emmenait dans dans les champs et
au vendée fil en aiguille on va dire il
ya une formation qui s'est créé sur pied
dans les boyaux et donc je me suis
inscrit à la formation et donc j'ai fait
4 2 en préformation et un bta et en même
temps que je faisais la formation de bpa
il y avait la commune qu'il y avait des
terres et avait concédé une banque et
donc j'ai été retenu ce domaine du
relais il y avait 54 hectares par contre
c'était des grandes surfaces à 54
hectares pour quatre exécuteurs c'est
vrai beaucoup j'ai acquérir ce terrain
dont il fait 12 hectares en surface
totale brute j'ai construit en allant
dire que j'ai commencé à faire de
l'essence du l'essentiel et après offert
mais j'ai commencé à mettre du match je
pense que le géranium c'est vrai que
c'est pas bien c'est un complément mais
pas de temps et bien la dépuille et ça
fait ça fait trente ans que je la vois
où les passionnés et ça et ça comme il
disait tout à l'heure un minot rend
compte que des passionnés qui fait
vraiment plaisir de voir que quoi qu on
en a on a des passionnés pour la réunion
qui bataille pour la population
réunionnaise parce que pour le coup
messieurs dames c'est sûr que si du plan
des carottes et pas seulement pour lui
laisse jolie et laisse entassés dans
deux caisses et le cip aux autres c'est
aussi pour nous les consommateurs
donc on me dit de toute façon il faut
arrêter là il faut consommer un peu le
cac 40 est bien d'accord avec moi
cousineau consommation et
c'est pas pousser se priva fatiga non
plus mais quand ça malheureusement
- miss a pas trop tarder bouyain mon
bain médium et c'est d'avoir créé un
noir de rien mais comme milieu au revoir
d'accord mitra vs mais ça va a plus tard
et d'ailleurs aucune comme ça fait une
salade carotte saluer dix de retrouvés
[Musique]
radio marca qui plaît allez pas les
hommes ont la forme de ron agam athènes
pas mon âme à nu mais mes tournées aux
notes platon étoiles supprimant viscas
esprit centre soleil la haine comme il
travaille comme pour 127 pour mamaï la
bataille mais tour continue-t-elle
vous voilà donc là on est juste en bas
de chez la maison de saïdiya
on est au domaine du relais un superbe
endroit où pique-niqué dans les eaux de
la petite scierie donc à l'époque ici
avait un grand kabar qui jurait
pratiquement 24 heures ok les petits
kiosques les petits endroits pour faire
à manger les petits sentiers en sachant
que tout en haut là vous avez des
sentiers de randonnée ben moi ce que je
vais faire si je fais une petite salade
de carottes 1
l'émission touche à sa fin mais je veux
pas pleurer non faut pas pleurer parce
qu'on va se retrouver
je crois même dimanche prochain on
retrouve donc la raison de s'affoler
enfin voyons un je lui dis tout
simplement aurevoir à la prochaine
d'accords et
[Musique]